this is the first episode of Crawford's
couch of the new NBA season it's only
right that my first guest is one of them
ones Jason Tatum L J as they call him in
St Louis a four time NBA Allstar Jason
Tatum Eastern Conference MVP Jason T
allstar game MVP Jason Tatum Jay you see
where I'm going with this you see what I
think is next in your future yeah I
think I get where you going next what
you think has to happen for you to get
that MVP award I think we got to be the
best team I think playing at an MVP
level is just as important as getting
the award you know if you're playing at
an MVP level you're impacting the game
on both ends of the floor and you're
impacting winning and that's most
important we've been so close these last
you know two three years of getting over
that hump you that's the main main goal
winning MVP would be a dream come true
but that equates there us winning the
two JS a little too much D and brown
continues to show the world he is him
boy is he fast obviously Ste sharp and
steal what's one thing you would steal
from his game to add to yours his
explosiveness what a move here that
first step to get past anybody lower his
shoulder through contact obviously he
works hard he got a lot of god-given
ability like his explosiveness and his
first step is something I've always you
know wish you know I
had Bill Russell Larry Bird kg Paul
Pierce and now you're the guy for such
an iconic franchise is it pressure
what's it like put on that uniform every
day us a sense of Pride knowing that all
the great people that paved the way in
this league way before I was even born
that I have the honor of wearing the
same uniform is Bill Russell and Larry
Bird and even now just having a great
relationship with Paul like I was with
Paul four to five weeks this summer in
La working out with him and stuff it's
been really cool cuz they've done
special things here they won
championship for them to just get around
and share some knowledge and share
stories it's an honor being here and
wearing a
uniform my favorite player is Michael
Jordan your guy is Kobe I had the
opportunity to get in the gym with MJ
when I was younger what do you remember
about being in the gym with Co how
nervous I was excited it was a full
circle moment like I couldn't even
express to him like yo you don't know
how much impact you had on my life
without us ever meeting you a big reason
why I pushed myself as hard as I did
while you know I worked out at 5:30 in
the morning because I knew you worked
out at 5:30 in the morning you know I
worked my whole life to get to the point
where I got to work out with the guy
that you know inspired me from a
distance here in Boston one game remains
in the Eastern Conference Finals between
the Celtics and Miami Heat I was
Courtside game seven at the Eastern
Conference Finals I can see who's
nervous I can see who's excited you were
like extremely focused and extremely
relaxed we all was like oh he's going
off for 50 T night you could see in your
eyes how disappointing was that for you
to get hurt that early in the game in
game seven and then how did that fure
work in Sun Tatum one to fire in the
lane crashing into Vincent and he
twisted an ankle perhaps that was a
tough K was swall this was the first
play of the game that left ankle he
rolled it pretty good as competitors you
live for those moments right game seven
is nothing better than that and I've had
my fav share I think I played in five of
those those are like the most fun games
to be a part of I'm never like too tight
before game I'm always relaxed I'm
always just like you know it's
basketball I'm about to go have fun so
that was my mindset going into it and I
was just excited for that opportunity we
fought back to come back from now 03 I
seen the staff played in 93% of the
games in my career like I I don't miss
games you know so for me to get hurt on
the first play of the game it just kind
of crushed me it was all to sleep for a
couple days I just felt like we didn't
have a chance that night just how it
unfolded after the first play and you
still try to gut it out and I remember
telling you after the game your idol
will be proud of you because we seen
guys like oh okay oh that's my that's my
moment to get away you know what I mean
like I ain't got to deal with the
pressure and everything else that comes
with
it I always say we teach our kids but at
times our kids are teaching us what has
Deuce taught you in his young life that
you didn't know about yourself patience
you you have to have patient he's
motivated me just to be a better you
know basketball player be a better
person I have somebody that wants to do
everything I do that responsibility of
somebody is you know always watching
talk about your mom Miss Brandy little
bit speak to how she's affected you in
your life she's a reason I am why I'm on
the court but off the court she raised
me to respect people to have humility
and always work hard I used to go to
class with my mom like we didn't have no
babysitter and I saw my mom get her law
degree her doctorate degree her master's
degree all while trying to make ends
meet and live check to check you know my
mom she ain't quit her job till after my
fourth year in the league even to this
day she works as hard as she ever did
watching my back making sure you know
everything off the court is taken care
of so IE with all to my mom I wouldn't
be who I am without her you know that's
like my best friend how' you come up
with zero limit scoutship me and my mom
would always talk St Louis is such a big
part of my life like I want to help
change the narrative I want to help
change the city I grew up in for the
Next Generation I always wanted to be
that guy in St Louis starting
scholarship funds for inner city kids
redesigning recreational centers in the
city I do a daddy induced toy and co-
Drive every Christmas I do a back to
school drive free basketball camps and
that's just like the beginning I'm
always trying to figure out ways to help
impact the city I grew up in I came from
this community I came from this rec
center and whatever you believe in
whatever you dream of whatever you
trying to accomplish that don't let
somebody tell you like oh she from St
Louis it's not realistic just being that
inspiration back home has always been
important to them word association St
Louis Nelly isoo it's my cousin Brighton
braad Bill Big Brother Kobe my idol
bro if I I want to say go if he ain't
the go he's second as as much credit as
he get he don't get enough I agree andj
here to go I don't think anyone plays
currently like you but if you were to
combine three players in NBA history to
kind of come close to how you play your
style and that what it looks like who
would you combine Paul George Kobe I
ain't that athletic but T-Mac I was
going to say T-Mac so yeah in three
that's a cold list blend them up you get
JT if you can have a pickup game you can
have any 10 players in NBA history
compete in the best game of the world
you can put it on the street wherever
you want to put let's put it St Louis
let's put it on the playground who do
you got who's your 10 including you this
might not be like the 10 best players
but these are nine other
guys
Kobe
Mike
Steph Allan Iverson oh KD BR Penny Penny
what number one cuz Penny all right
Gilbert arenus that's why I we're number
zero I never knew that okay that's he I
would say Magic Johnson I wish I like
could have saw him play that's my second
favorite player ever magic won three
championships in four years on three
different levels so in a foure span he
won a high school college in the NBA
Championship magic was cold yeah there
it is bro I appreciate you taking time
you are first guest and for a reason I
feel like you're truly like the leader
of the new school and you kind of bridg
the Gap cuz you like a a young OG not
old at all but you accomplish so much
already just inspiring to see so we'll
stay T Jay appreciate you I'm man
appreciate
you